in April of 1968 Martin Luther King was
assassinated the small number
african-american students created a
black Students Union at MIT the Black
Student Union presented a list of
demands to the administration except we
actually called them proposals we felt
that MIT could be significantly enhanced
by having more minority students here
and many people questioned our right to
be here at MIT many people questioned
our abilities to succeed at the academic
endeavor there were people who question
whether African American students had
the capacity to innovate in intellectual
fields we created a summer program
called Project interphase which still
operates and was staffed largely by
African Americans graduate students we
wanted to do what we could to ease the
transition into MIT I was in the first
project interphase which took place in
1969 part of the thing was to bring them
up to the campus the summer before they
would start so they could learn the
campus so they could meet each other and
so they would come here not feel like
they were on an island I had to learn
how to study and manage my time all that
happened during project interphase for
me we taught get up to speed subjects in
physics and math there was a humanities
program there was an athletics and
social program we weren't just being
taught by MIT professors we were being
taught by other minority students many
of whom had gone through interphase that
weren't peers but were role models for
you as well a couple of our students in
project interphase who had not had
calculus in high school came to project
an efficient learn calculus and then
placed out of 1801 and 1802 and with
that Launchpad it made it easier to take
a risk to step out to have confidence to
be courageous all those things that got
me through MIT and it's gotten
through my life sense so interface was
this experiment that kind of said you
know yeah these people can do this the
best way to solve a problem is to bring
multiple perspective to their problem
and the best way to solve the problems
of the world is to make sure that all
the people that touch that problem are
taken into account as you drive to the
solution Paul created an amazing
foundation and so there wouldn't be a
real presence if it weren't for what
went on during that period maybe the
most important thing I did around here
uh-ohhh a large portion of my success at
MIT and I would even say since MIT to
interface project interphase was the
singular most important academic
experience I ever had in my life
one could hope that you wouldn't need an
interface anymore because all the
disparities are gone and we're all very
diverse and all the stakeholders are
engaged but that's not the case and so I
think that the work of interphase is so
important changing the lives of students
like myself attributing to the success
of MIT and the impact and footprint that
it's making on society at large so we'll
go 45 more years until we don't need to
exist anymore
you